luego de una primera información sobre
la base de un test de antígenos este
sábado se confirmó mediante pcr que el
presidente alberto fernández tiene 19
tiene coronavirus el gobierno a la
presidencia dio a conocer un parte
médico del médico presidencial
federico saavedra que dice que el
presidente fernández está estable que
está bien que no presenta síntomas y que
espera además un progreso positivo
porque ha sido además vacunado ya con
dos dosis en su caso de la vacuna
sputnik ve que casi en la totalidad de
los casos hasta donde se conocen el 100%
de los casos previene enfermedades
graves de coronavirus mientras tanto
estuvieron llegando al país a través de
diferentes medios especialmente de sus
cuentas de twitter saludos y buenos
deseos de mandatarios y políticos de la
región como el presidente de méxico
andrés manuel lópez obrador el de chile
sebastián piñera y los ex presidentes de
brasil lula da silva de bolivia evo
morales y de ecuador rafael correa todos
deseando una pronta recuperación un
pronto pasaje de esta enfermedad para el
presidente argentino alberto fernández